Speaker 1: All right. The pollsters really
don't know what's going to happen tonight.
And I have been a defender of polling to the
extent that we understand the methodology being
used. You might remember that the right loves to
say the pollsters got it really wrong in 2016.
They really didn't. The national popular vote
polls said it would be a three point margin by
which Hillary would win, and Hillary won by a
little over two points in the national popular
vote. The polling was correct, but it did not
correctly get the electoral vote because that
came down to very small margins in a few states.
So the the general overarching attacks on polling,
I'm not big on them. They're not super interesting
to me. But it is true that in these particular
midterms, the polls may not reflect what's going
to happen tonight. There's a very good Daily Beast
article called Pollsters Have No Effing Idea
What's Going to Happen This Election. And it
says pollsters and election handicappers are
very worried they could be wrong in decisive
ways for the 2022 midterms. Now, this is a this is
a this is a result of two big things. Number one,
the margins, particularly in the Senate, are
expected to be very small. So when you're most
likely outcome is one party has 51 seats or the
other party has 51 seats. That's already a range
that only comes down to a couple of seats. Many of
these races are super close because Fetterman is
a tie. Walker Warnock is a tie. That's your Senate
right there. That's your, you know, all else being
equal. Those two races that are ties determine who
controls the Senate. So because it's very close,
even a small margin of error can be one party
controls the Senate or another party controls
the Senate. The other thing that's going on is
that there are growing issues and you can read
the article, we'll link to it. There are growing
issues with the polling in two particular ways. A
lot of the aggregators, like Real Clear Politics,
are using a lot of overtly right wing pollsters
in their calculations. So just for example,
like if you look at Walker Warnock, you see
that Trafalgar is being included in the average.
Trafalgar is a known right leaning pollster. So
is that throwing off the numbers? That's one
thing. And then number two, to some degree.
You know, a lot of people don't pick up calls
from unknown numbers at all anymore. And there
is starting to be a side from the stuff that's
done online for the phone stuff. There's starting
to potentially be a sort of self-selection bias
in the people that are interested in getting on
the phone and talking to a pollster. And it can
include people who want to sway the polls in a
particular way. Okay. So the point here is it's
Election Day, ignore the polls, but also the
polls really may not be telling us what's going
to happen tonight. Now, here's the danger of this
right wing skew to the polls, if indeed there is
one. You know, we're going to look at clips later.
The right is telling us they're going to
claim fraud. They're going to do it. It's
they're going to claim fraud. And one of the
ways they may claim that fraud is by saying,
did you see the polls leading up to the election?
You expect us to believe that despite the polls,
all these Democrats won. Now, these are the
very same people who in elections past say
you can't trust the polls, but they are going to
weaponize this right wing push polling to say,
look at the polls and look at what you tell us
was the actual vote. That's not believable. It
must have been rigged. That's the danger. We
will have results in a few hours and then we
can put the polling question aside. Republicans
are already suing to throw out mail in ballots.